[Applause] and they play on off the skate of
Jake Bean lead pass to troch he's in pass across
score a beautiful setup from to to L forier
and they counter attack in a hurry here comes
the turnover paner to tro and to laier and panan
now has points in 14 straight to start the season
paner makes a defensive play and lir finishes
it off Faceoff one by tro guson to paner save
M Lin with a right pad p and again he shoots
in for crer they score Alex laier has tied the
game with the 11 seconds to go it's
33 that's clutch
baby paner with the shot beautiful pass coming
up here from crder watch it just to the other
side First's lincol couldn't control the rebound
on the paner and shot and a heads up play by Wier
right here just tips it over to the other
side and laer bangs it in to tie it second
goal of the game for Alexa La a bouncer that's
stopped by m lincol played it to prar off and
this game is going to overtime the Rangers
have a point and now Alexi L forier up for
the Rangers a twogo game tonight the big TI goal
in the closing seconds and now a chance to give
the Rangers the lead in the shootout L frenier
moves in and he scores what a backand by Alexa
laier you talk about smooth how about this
all in one motion just under the crossbar
over the love can Jonathan Quick make one
more save oh this is it Alexander texier
comes in on quick and a sa it's on top of
the net brers [Applause] win they love it
at the Garden Jonathan Quick picks up his
fourth win of the Season an outstanding
performance the Rangers led by Alex laier
two goals and the winner in the shootout